Chris is in Virginia hi Chris how are
you good how are you doing thanks for
taking my call
sure what's up well I've run a business
for 10 years and we just had our 10 year
anniversary but I'm kind of celebrating
by considering chapter 11 and I mean
I've been over everything and racking my
brains trying everything I could and it
just seems like that's probably the best
play right now to fix some of the
problems and in there and so I just I
know you've been through bankruptcy of
one form or another and I just any
advice as far as you know making sure
that that is the right trigger to pole
well I just you know the thing that
bankruptcy is in the same category is
divorce it's the last thing you do after
you tried everything else and I don't so
I don't recommend it I went through it
but that doesn't mean I recommend it
it's not a method of building wealth
that's for sure so how much of that have
you got on this business it's about two
hundred fifty thousand right now it's a
seasonal business so what is the what is
the debt on one a hundred thousand is a
business line of credit hundred thousand
is a rapid advance type of deal and
rapid advance yeah it's the time that
seemed like was trying everything else
right as a service on that every month
is really what's killing us business is
starting to appear you know we're
getting into a busier time but we're
just so far behind it and what's the
other 50,000 there's about thirty on a
credit card and then about twenty
between family members okay
and the line of credit the business line
of credit is just secured on your home
and I'm not a hundred percent sure I
know that the other hundred thousand is
the rapid advances on your home well I'm
well here's the deal I signed for it you
know I know you sign for all of it well
right
they don't make loans to biz
is like yours unless you sign for him
you have personal this is it this is all
personal debt technically speaking but
we did it for the business now okay what
kind of business moving okay
and what were you buying with all this
stuff just trying to stay open yeah it's
just okay so what do you prophets are
you paying taxes on I'm not even sure
what our profits are right now you know
it's a 1.4 million dollar business for
the longest time we had a workman's
compensation insurance premium of over
12,000 about $12,000 a month a couple of
claims have pushed us up there we went
from 1800 to 12,000 in the space of a
few months and then we we maintained
that for a few years but then we start
taking of it to get us to slow time and
you know the first thing you have to
figure out before you need to file
chapter 11 is you need to figure out if
you're making a profit or not you may
not need to watch out for 11 you may
need to just close it well really true I
mean operating something that's not
profitable is kind of silly that's like
a hobby so I'll tell you what hold on a
minute when we come back to this break
I'll talk to you a little bit more and
hang with me this is the Dave Ramsey
show
I'm talking with Chris in Virginia he's
got $250,000 out in a line of credit and
rapid advance and family on a moving
business
that's seasonal and doesn't know if he's
making a profit hasn't seen a P&L got a
top line of over a million dollars he
thinks and wondering if he's in Chapter
11 you wouldn't be so far Chris yeah
okay the first thing you've got to do
and you're gonna do this file chapter
living anyways you're going to build a
P&L need to build a profit loss
statement and you can start primitive
and and get a little bit more
sophisticated with a million dollar
business don't have to have a ton of
sophistication but basically your income
minus your outgo equals your profit you
know that right
and the first step is do it on yellow
pad the second step sit sit down with an
accountant then begin to lay that out
have you not been paying your taxes no
no everything virtually everything is
paid up to this point but okay so if
you've been paying your taxes how did
you do that without a pl well we have we
have an accounting team okay we gotta
take counts into that actual accountants
not in-house or anything that then
developed your tax returns which shows
your profit right and I've been talking
to them they said we don't understand
you should be profitable I should be
profitable and you know we looked like
the positive 39% you know or no excuse
me production wages was at 39% they made
the suggestion that we cut that down to
29 it would be a but if you have a
million two and you've got $400,000 or
$450,000 and production expenses meaning
your labor costs that seems even low
it's probably above that then what other
expenses you've got you got insurance
and you've got your you talked about
your workers comp is high that would be
normal in your business and then you've
got truck operations and rental and our
truck operations and insurance ideal in
a building or you got a rental building
we were we are leasing right now okay
don't release a month about 8,000 okay
that's 100 grand a year so you should be
profitable let's pretend that we do all
of this and you find $200,000 a year
profit which you should have the numbers
you're giving me
I'm not unless there's something I'm
missing in this bow then I think more
than anything you are disorganized you
can say that yeah you know and when you
get organized and you go WOW where's all
this money going that might solve the
problem chapter 11 doesn't solve doesn't
make you organized and you'll go back
you'll lose the business if you don't
get your arms around it you're gonna
you're going down because you're not
running the business of businesses
running you you're stressed out yeah
you're just trying to out earn your
disorganization you're trying to make
enough money to cover up all the crap
okay the fact that you've been you know
you work really hard lifting furniture
but you don't work hard at your business
well running the running of your
business if I was going to hire you for
an Operations Manager I would fire you
and you would - mmm because I'm talking
to you you can't tell me if you're
profitable right I can tell you what
I've been told that by the accountant no
that's you own the business saying you
own the pinellas you're responsible for
it so I don't give a crap
what's your accountant say I want you to
get on the phone with them when you get
off of me and get a yellow pad out and
on the top of that yellow pad I want you
to put your grocery venes and then I
want you to just find out from them on
the tax return where the money went
and then get your checkbook out and
figure out where the money went
you have an accounting system with your
checkbook yes I mean with QuickBooks you
actually use it okay you know then it
ought to give you a monthly P&L dude
mm-hmm QuickBooks does a P&L for you get
your get your accountant in there and
help you work through that if you don't
know how to work through it and let's
figure out what your profits are because
if you're making $200,000 a year you
just put your household on starvation
diet and let's get this mess cleaned up
mm-hmm
and as I understand Chapter eleven that
puts some of the debt on hold at least
for a little while I know it's a big
black eye but that gives you a chance to
you're not even listening to me or
restructure right you're not even
listening to me are you you're not
bankrupt you don't even know if you're
bankrupt
we're out of money that's what I know at
this point okay dude if you want to fix
this I told you how to fix it but by
Chapter eleven is not your answer you're
gonna go Chapter seven and you're gonna
lose the whole business if you go into
an eleven that's what's gonna happen
because you don't know where's what's
going on in your business you're gonna
have to run your business to turn this
thing around if you do that you're
probably not a chapter 11 if you don't
do that a chapter 11 is going to ensure
you lose the whole thing that's what's
going to happen for you I hope that
doesn't happen